now let's bring you some developing news
coming to us here Israeli forces have
killed a Palestinian man after he opened
fire at an illegal settlement in the
occupied West Bank six Israelis were
injured in the shooting Hamas says the
attack was in response to settler
incursions at the Al-Aqsa mosque on
Thursday led by Israel's
ultra-nationalist security minister
itamar Ben gevir Laura Khan joins us now
on the line from occupied East Jerusalem
what can you tell us Laura
yes absolutely we're just getting
information about this now that it
happened in the illegal settlement of
ma'ale adamin which is kind of Midway
through the occupied West Bank just
north of Bethlehem it happened in a
shopping mall as the police say they've
shot dead a man in his 20s they haven't
yet identified who he is and the Israeli
Ambulance Service says they've now
raised the toll of the Wounded in the
shooting attack to five people and
they've been taken to hospital in
Jerusalem they say a man in his 40s is
seriously hurt while four others
including a 14 year old boy
um are moderately injured so we're just
waiting for more information on that at
the moment um they did say that the
Israeli police chief and the far-right
national security minister isma Ben
gavir I now headed to the settlement um
and just to say today uh we've actually
been driving through the occupied West
Bank
um from an area which is considered an
area and see under full Israeli military
and administrative control and we saw a
number of settlers moving into an
archeology Park in sebastia on our way
back we were stopped at numerous
checkpoints and made a way for well over
an hour so it seems as though there has
been a fair amount of tension
particularly today in the West Bank many
people were stuck in traffic jams at
checkpoints with soldiers and apparently
there were a fair few settler incursions
um illegales into the occupied West Bank
so we will keep an eye on this situation
for you and Laura just give us a little
bit of context about where these
settlements sit with vis-a-vis
international law
well detectment are illegal that is
illegal under the United Nations under
international law and one of the biggest
concerns actually is with the the
hardest like government in Israel's
history and amid the mass protest
against
um you know a lot of what they're trying
to pass through law many today that
because there are so many settlers now
inside the Israeli cabinet but they are
essentially creating a kind of settler
coup inside the occupied West Bank so
part of their agenda has been to
increase settlement expansion in the
West Bank and and just um you know
spending fun in the West Bank you can
see it between Palestinian cities
um you know driving from Janine for
example
um since two hours drive down to Ramada
you can see customers on almost every
Hill you can see more and more settlers
walking down into Palestinian streets so
this is really the kind I'm fat on the
ground and it's deeply disturbing and
the Palestinian Authority has been
speaking out about a time of time
um this year they are going to the
international court of justice as well
um to talk about the legality
um of the consequences of the occupation
um but of course uh you know there are
more than 700 000 that was living in
occupied uh in the occupied West Bank
um so it's just become a fact on the
ground to the Palestinians living there
all right thanks so much Laura Khan
there